[Musique]
bienvenue sur le plateau d' interdit
d'interdire je reçois le paléontologue
valéry zeitoun pour le grand atlas homo
sapiens qui vient de paraître chez
glénat la grande aventure yeux de
l'humanité en 3 millions d'années qui va
nous raconter dans un instant fadda
freddy ndongue 10 dont gaudy qui sortent
le sixième album de daradji family ya ma
télé et seront en concert au trianon
vendredi prochain et benoît duteurtre
pour son nouveau livre les dents de la
mer ou les souffrances d'un piéton de
paris qui vient de paraître chez fayard
mais commençons tout de suite par notre
époque qu'est ce qui la caractérise
voici leurs réponses en images on
commence par votre image menu adulte
entre ouï dire que c'est de votre au
delà même de ceux de ce livre où je
parle beaucoup de paris parce que c'est
un peu partout pareil c'est l'invasion
des marques dans les villes la
transformation des villes en alignement
de logo d'anciennes et c'est quelque
chose que je trouve extrêmement pénible
et très caractéristique de l'époque j'ai
parfois quand je me promène dans une rue
maintenant j'ai l'impression de me
promener dans une allée d'un grand
magasin avec la succession des enseignes
de la zec autant de nourriture rapide de
téléphone etc
et effectivement pour les grands travaux
on sollicite maintenant les entreprises
alors ils font un gros effort financier
mais est ce qu'on a vraiment besoin
voilà de transformer les villes en
affiche pur affichage publicitaire frais
dès votre image à vous je sais pas si
c'est l'image de fadda freddy ou 2 go
django 10 c'est à dire bouquet est ce
soit ben bassat c'est le professeur
figurines star tu écris dans votre album
d'ailleurs il commence qui a fait là
la préface si on pourrait dire de
l'album via ma télé qui est aussi
économiste musicien est aussi historien
donc c'est le professeur beloufa bizarre
donc qui est très ancrée en ce moment
sur la restitution des oeuvres donc des
des oeuvres africaines sont aujourd'hui
dans le monde et que l'afrique voudrait
bien récupérer on à faire débat
d'ailleurs sur ce sujet récemment mais
il n'était pas là et vous votre image
jeune gone de j arrive pas de nom en
gros dit voilà alors moi mon image c'est
l'image de d'un grand guide spirituel de
kaolack qu'on appelle cheikh ibrahim
niass pour moi qui à plusieurs
dimensions parce qu'il ya l'homme scheib
la menace est malheureusement cette
dimension fait qui sort du cadre là où
je vois mieux quand voilà donc il ya
l'homme qui a deux dimensions la
dimension vraiment le professeur de
guides mais aussi qui a traversé le
temps et aujourd'hui qui a laissé un
livre qu'on appelle l'afrique aux
africains et donc qui continue quand
même à à guider les jeunes africains
dans la spiritualité dans la news et
vous venez zeitoun d'autres images
restent un comble de modernité là bas
pas forcément alors l'image halal à
trois raisons la première c'était pour
coller un petit peu avec l'atlas l'idée
c'était de dire que voilà la classe un
survol de l'humanité sur une certaine
profondeur de temps en même temps c'est
un petit signal envoyé à tous ses
directeurs ces grands pdg des instituts
français qui ont du mal à comprendre que
c'est la collaboration qui permet
d'aboutir à ce genre de fait assez
important pour l'humanité est le
troisième volet ben c'est que c'est le
premier selphy fait dans l'espace et là
s'interroge sur autre chose sûre entre
guillemets gerin tout ça pour ça
est-ce qu'ils aident à l'est aussi lourd
pour se photographier la tête bon de la
tête fait d'autres trucs
certainement mais voilà en tout cas
c'était ce qui la convergence de ces
trois points pour pour et ça donne très
très belle image quand même tout le
monde peut pas faire à cette fille comme
ça tout à fait mais est ce que ce serait
nécessaire que chacun fasse ce qu'elle
fit je m'interroge tout de même et bien
commençons
[Musique]
la belle et zeitoun vous êtes
paléontologue et avec telmo pavani vous
publiez homo sapiens qui est donc un
atlas qui vient de paraître chez glénat
c'est la place de l'humanité 1
on va tout de suite voir des cartes
parce qu'il y en a beaucoup beaucoup
danse libre qu'on bouffe de regarder la
première c'est celle du la vallée du
grand rift
alors qu'est ce qu'elle a bien
intéressant cette carte qu'est ce
qu'elle nous explique alors bon c'est
c'est une image parmi d'autres par
définition c'est un atlas donc là l'idée
c'était de nous ramener un petit peu ce
grande histoire qu'on nous raconte
depuis plusieurs années maintenant
qui nous dit qu'il ya eu des choses des
événements importants concernant
l'humanité les humanités mêmes qui sont
produites sur le continent africain
pour des raisons physiologiques oui donc
c'est le tremblement de terre c'est ça
c'est en fait le rif c'est comme une
scène création d'un océan finalement qui
va séparer à terme le l'afrique sur 6000
km à peu près 1 voilà tout à fait donc
c'est ce qu'on a au fond des skis
traverse l'islande un plus haut à donc
c'est à peu près ce phénomène là qui qui
est très active depuis surtout trois
millions d'années et à cette période là
en tout cas aux alentours un peu avant
évidemment c'est pas partout pareil
ce que là aussi ce qui est intéressant
de ce qu'on va voir peut-être sur deux
les différentes cartes si on a forcément
une vision statique et mobile mais en
réalité tous chaque image est une
accumulation d'événements donc c'est une
simplification à chaque fois évidemment
et l'a donc ce qui se passe à ce niveau
là en tout cas c'est ce qu'on a
longtemps cru c'est que à l'ouest il y
avait les grands singes les gorilles les
chimpanzés et leurs ancêtres et puis
alès il y avait
les premières humanité les parents trope
les australopithèques ça se partage
comme ça à ce partage et il ya des
environnements qui sont différents il
sort a été ça voilà ça s'est ouverte ce
serait dressée sur nos pattes mes
arrières pourquoi faire ça vous regardez
dans la sava ça déjà c'est une vieille
histoire est finie des jusqu'à 2,6 1995
on sait qu'il ya des australopithèques
au tchad par exemple est donc ce ce
modèle cette théorie là ne
fonctionnerait qu'il fonctionnait bien
qu'ils étaient très séduisant ne
marchent déjà vu et c'est ça c'est abc
on va voir si c'est exactement de ses
dix millions d'années la bipédie à peu
près 1
alors on va être beaucoup dans les
grands chine je risque de me corriger
quand je parle aux étudiants aujourd'hui
penser que c'est des euros mais comme
ils les ont pas ils ont aussi du mal
entre cent mille et un million ils
n'arrivent pas à palper finalement le
nil gros nous regardons la liberté quand
ce landais piketty sur lui et l'a
reconnu alors c'est l'ardipithecus dpt
cuche alors c'est un de ces ce qu'on
appelle un taxon assez une catégorie
qu'on n'aime pas
qui qui aurait déjà eu j'aurais déjà
pratiqué la bipédie qui pourrait être un
des trois candidats à ce qui est ce que
sont nos cousins les plus anciens qui
auraient pratiqué la bipédie mais en
même temps on a eu des nouvelles données
notamment l'année dernière on a trouvé
un parce que tu as bien sage 1 me
laissait pas vraiment le terme mais une
sorte de en tout cas un primate en
allemagne qui a 11 millions d'années qui
a déjà une idée des membres inférieurs
qui indiquent qu'il y avait déjà de la
bipédie et donc de nos jours on est plus
que c'est la bipédie qui va conduire à
l'humanité il ya eu différentes bipédie
et puis bah les lignes et se sont
éteintes et puis c'est la nôtre qui a
réussi à bondir à profiter de cette vie
paisible pour en faire quelque chose
alors que d'autres taxes auparavant donc
pas réussi entre guillemets parce qu'il
n'y a pas de réussite dans ces
affaires-là way tout dépend du hasard et
de l'environnement alors on va voir
lucie corps est bien connu ce qui est à
droite de l'uci on voit les plus
anciennes empreinte de l'humanité connu
jusqu'à présent
empreintes fossilisées alors en fait
sont les empreintes de pas les plus
anciennes connues
ouais est ce qu'en réalité les plus
anciennes empreinte entre guillemets le
camp veut dire éléments qui montrent que
le des humains en tout cas des primates
plus exactement on fait quelque chose ça
remonte à 3 3 millions d'années et là on
a des traces de découpe d'ossements donc
on peut penser qu'il ya quelqu'un dans
la lute il ya quelqu'un qui a découpé de
la viande
et puis les vrais outils donc qu'ils
sont fabriqués pour le coup parce que
l'on en a que des traces c'est au tour
de trois millions d'années c'est
toujours dans cette partie des dépenses
est évidemment des empreintes de part
les empreintes de pas ou alors ses 22
passes l'ancien et à côté le dessin qui
les reconstituent il aurait noté comme
ça alors l'histoire c'est d'après les
études on va dire biomécanique et ses
empreintes c'est de dire quand rouhia il
ya un couple et un plus jeune qui aurait
suivi derrière
donc voilà donc c'est en tout cas là la
preuve indirecte d'une démarche bipèdes
dans les cendres volcaniques qui n'était
pas encore consolidée à l'époque elle
regarde les suivantes
alors lui on l'a découvert il ya assez
récemment et c'est en 2017 et et il
aurait eu la capacité à la fois de
marcher sur ses deux pattes arrière mais
aussi de continuer à aller dans les
arbres il ya pas mal de bouleverser
notre vision et bat pas tant que ça
parce que déjà c'est ce qu'on reprochait
ou ce qu'on attribue aux
australopithèques déjà sagna ben voilà
oui c'est à dire qu'il ya il ya comment
dire il ya une partie anatomique et
plutôt le scot post crânien on va dire
les jambes et le membre inférieur qui
serait adaptée à la bipédie par contre
la partie antérieure du corps seraient
encore habité enfin permettra encore de
la boire dans les arts et en fait on
peut très bien concevoir que bah on
puisse faire les deux et que en fonction
de l'environnement pratique l'un ou
l'autre mais voilà il n'y a pas de
raison que ça soit stricte et qu' ils
sont interdits grimper dans les arbres
qui sont intermittentes
ecstasy balaya plus d'arbres alors
forcément on se dresse sur nos pattes
arrière alors ce n'était pas tout à fait
ça c'était plus un disque on dirait
simplificateur pour laisser à comprendre
qu'il y avait une évolution mais malgré
sa fin cette simplification on est un
peu une vision à la fois gradualiste et
déterministe et sa cécile complètement
abandonné de nogent suivante une carte
encore la carte c'est ce serait la carte
de la façon dont nous sommes sortis
d'africains alors les homo sapiens
allait enfin pas les homo sapiens les
premiers à sortir d'afrique c'est ce
qu'on appelle les homo ergaster c'est
une sorte de ce qu'on appelait avant des
homo erectus qu'on a à dire segmenté en
différentes catégories et en fait ce
genre de carte peut aussi c'est une
compilation de plusieurs événements sur
plusieurs dizaines centaines de milliers
d'années est donc la première maudire
preuves tangibles vraiment où là il n'ya
pas il n'y a pas photo si je puis dire
c'est en géorgie avec homo ergaster 1,8
million d'années
donc là on a on a un humain qui est
sortis d'afrique il ya des outils à côté
on voit la variations anatomiques
mais il ya aussi des données en asie
mais alors ça ce sont des données
indirects évidemment contestée et
contestable certainement puisque là on a
des évidences non panne atomique mais
sur du matériel qui était taillée
qu'aurait 2 millions d'années par
exemple à londres ou en chine alors
regardons par exemple ceux qui sont
allés en georgie voilà c'est le site de
nam isimat ici donc en géorgie voilà oui
à la voile alors leur crâne alors les
lieux un ouais alors ce qui est
intéressant c'est que c'est aux portes
de l'europe
donc ça c'est quelque chose d'assez
nouveau par rapport à la vision qu'on
avait ce qu'on appelait la sortie
d'afrique en réalité plusieurs sorties
d'afrique
est ce qu'il faut pas oublier qu'on
reparle de sortie d'afrique section peut
en sortir on peut aussi rentrer c'est
pour ça que ses flèches ont toujours été
faites dans les deux sens d'ailleurs osé
l'atlas ont failli en venir aux charges
y retourner après tout à fait il n'y a
pas de raison
il n'y avait pas de sens unique à
l'époque et puis surtout n'ai pas de
carte pour savoir où aller donc je pense
qu'on va voir là les populations sont
dépassés déplacées au cours du temps en
fonction des environnements les plus
propices et voilà donc la sq intéressant
effectivement c'est que ça c'est une
fouquet grande comme comme le studio ici
c'est pas plus grand que ça et il ya
tous ces fossiles qui sont réunis qui
sent plus sous une coulée basaltique
qu'on peut parfaitement date et enfin 8
millions d'années dont classés et puis
et des outils c'est vraiment un site
parfait et oui c'est pas toujours le cas
parfois c'est plus compliqué
effectivement laissé vide
je me suis plus que c'est la suivante on
l'avait regardé vous la reconnaissez
alors ça c'est un pur casser ainsi
espagnol l'espagne
alors là il ya une profusion de
spécimens avec toutes les parties
anatomiques représentait donc ça c'est
quelque chose qui était vraiment
révolutionnaire puisque ça permet
d'avoir presqu'une une notion
démographique paléo démographique de ces
hommes fossiles alors pour cela ils ont
environ trois cent mille ans va dire
cela et leurs ancêtres sont plus anciens
en espagne ils ont huit cent mille ans
donc voilà pour pour amener un côté un
petit peu chauvin on va dire que c'est
ce qu'on a de l'autre côté des pyrénées
à tautavel fait on va voir maintenant
homo antecessor alors celui là tout le
monde ne le connais pas remonter ses
sorts en réalité ce sont les plus vieux
humains d'atapuerca ou d'à côté voilà
c'est ce qui était en europe avant
l'homme moderne
alors oui tout à fait ce sont les
premiers humains connu en europe
et d'ailleurs les en 1998 quand les
collègues espagnols l'ont défini on a
ils ont dit que au monde entier ses
sorts étaient les ancêtres communs des
néandertaliens et des hommes modernes
donc voilà donc moi que j'ai tendance à
dire que c'est des zones où sapiens tout
court mais puisque les si on considère
que les hommes modernes sont des zones
on serait bien sapiens et les noms
derrière les homo sapiens
neanderthalensis ce qui les réunissent
au bout c'est bien ce qu'il faut ça il
faut se souvenir que vous l'avez dit
d'ailleurs il ya d humidité il ya
plusieurs espèces humaines qui en tout
cas cohabitent toi en tout cas sont
contemporaines alors évidemment ce à
l'échelle des temps géologiques inza
comme toutes ses flèches toutes ses
cartes
c'est une compilation d'événement est là
aussi alors à l'échelle buttons qui est
la nôtre et on peut dire qu'ils
donc cohabiter sur la planète en
touraine à une époque où on se rend
compte très peu
vous devez pas de très nombreux non plus
d'en gagner faire un commentaire
benoît duteurtre on va tous alors bien
sûr vous savez ici pas ça pour faire
plaisir à vraiment pas ce que je peux
même partie de l'association des amis du
jardin des plantes et du muséum
j'adore l'histoire de cette science elle
même qui nous raconte si bien mais moi
ya une question que vous pose depuis
toujours je pense pas que vous vouliez
de réponse mais c'est à partir de quand
nos ancêtres ont éprouvé pour la
première fois une émotion esthétique
comme par exemple de contempler à
coucher de soleil prochaine je peux pas
vous dire oui je peux éventuellement
évoqué la les périodes et les endroits
où on a de l'arche il y aura tiff ou
symbolique on va les voir les premiers
objets symboliques et en gros alors ça
aussi on a longtemps cru que c'était le
fait que le fait de l'homme moderne et
que c'était en europe impact aussi de
douves et relation sa part la tête et
aux réalités on s'aperçut que tous ces
faits là était connu trente mille ans
plus tôt en afrique
ouais et puis à l'époque de la grotte
chauvet rojo trente six mille quarante
mille ans on a aussi des peintures en
sulawesi donc il y à il ya eu on va dire
pluralité d'expression et on n'est pas
en état de pouvoir dire que c'était
forcément des hommes modernes
on a aussi pas de modernité entre
guillemets pour les néandertaliens
puisque en europe par exemple on l'est
on les a dans les dents les restes
fossiles et ils sont contemporains de
certains incertaine chose qui s'apprend
très de la ou des choses figuratif donc
voilà donc la modernité n'est pas
forcément le propre de mouzon alors la
modernité en tout cas à une époque
c'était ce que l'on va voir maintenant
c'est à dire une hutte
voilà ça c'était extrêmement moderne n'a
pas tout moment où loeb à la fois
colonisés le feu on voit qu'il ya de la
fumée mais construit ses huttes
alors s'il va se répandre dans le monde
entier l'a alors bonjour mais là en fait
il est déjà quasiment pas ce n'est pas
partout ça c'est en tout cas pour ce qui
est de la maîtrise du feu les premiers
indices paul veut dire l'utilisation du
feu c'est comme 1,7 million d'années en
afrique
donc c'est très loin mais là on commence
à avoir une sorte de généralisation est
encore marqué quelques points
exagère jausiers généralisation savent
environ 400 milan où là on a des foyers
maîtriser alors en chine en europe en
afrique donc vous peut dire que la
partie ces périodes là les humains ce
qu'elle aussi est plus d'humanité de la
maîtrise le feu quant à ce type de
cabanes ont les reconstituent par
rapport à des vestiges qui sont surtout
connues dans les territoires à dire
froid où les choses ont été bien
conservés ou effectivement lors par
exemple des des structures avec des
pierres et puis des ossements de
mammouths par exemple ça s'est déplacé
récente
sinon les cabanons soit il ya altamira
en france montpensier une cabane qui est
fait en bord de mer d'ailleurs voilà il
ya mécènes pour avoir la vue voilà la
nuitée tennis c'est comme ça que vous
qu'on l'appelle alors ça c'est quelque
chose de passionnant
on voit là une mère et son enfant un
conte à retrouver tel quel
évidemment ce qui est très intéressant
c'est que le le petit des êtres humains
on est au bout de neuf mois donc on est
totalement dépendant des parents quand
on aime on reste un enfant beaucoup plus
longtemps que la plupart des autres
espèces alors là je parle des espèces
qui ne sont pas humaine les autres prix
materi particulièrement
alors en fait pour l'année au tennis à
ce phénomène qui remonte à beaucoup plus
loin que ce cas précis au présent qui
s'il s'agit d'un homme moderne car
environ cent mille ans quand même avec
un proche orient la néoténie c'est ce
qui va qui commence déjà à paris que les
australopithèques et même chez les
parents trope avec un faciès plus
juvénile qui va perdurer plus longtemps
jusqu'à l'âge adulte
alors ce qui est plus vrai pour nous les
humains c'est que nous on a pu ces
superstructures s'y développer qu'on
l'ait pas rentrer up ou les
australopithèques et nous du coup on va
garder encore plus vrai pour nous les
modernes
on a une configuration anatomy et
surtout du crâne qui est globulaires qui
ressemble
en gros je caricature un à un jeune
chimpanzé par exemple voilà pour faire
quelque chose de très simple et de cours
voilà nos tennis et ça c'est le fait de
conserver des caractères
jeunes individus ce qui va de pair aussi
avec le fait que les parents doivent
s'occuper plus longtemps et d'éduquer
les jeunes
ouais alors images suivantes voilà ça
c'est lobo sapiens c'est nous en fait
certains d'entre nous et ouais parce
qu'on n'était pas tous comme ça
évidemment non mais voilà les mêmes
caractéristiques qu'ils allaient même
oui oui s'il entrait dans le dans le
studio là avec sera au retard de tout il
ne serait pas l'impression de voir un
extraterrestre quelqu'un qui est sur la
halle qui seront extraits je ne saurais
pas me prononcer alors on va voir
je sais plus ce qu'on voit là ah bah oui
si c'est là la vraiment c'est là on est
on est dans l'intelligence symbolique de
parler alors parler benoît tout à
l'heure la cdc néandertal je suis
reconstitution à gauche de la tombe
qu'on a trouvé à droite real ce qu'on
voit c'est une sépulture rituel donc
c'est des croyances alors en fait c'est
pas tout à fait la même scène s'est
passée parcelles kalou c'est sale con
qu'on attribue généralement un
néandertalien en irak mais le site de
shanidar où ils auraient trouvé comme ça
des des indices de pollen alors c'est
pas si sûr qu'elle soit finalement donc
on à rapprocher de ça vous fait d'avoir
mis des fleurs dans la sépulture
mais ce qui compte ici ce qui c'est de
voir que chez cette humanité là les
néandertaliens on pratique déjà le fait
funéraire c'est à dire que on se
préoccupe
d'une certaine manière alors on le voit
sur d'autres indices des anciens on voit
bien qu'il ya des gens qui sont extraits
au pied donc ont vécu à malgré la
blessure donc on s'est occupé d'eux et
on s'est occupé d'autres aussi au delà
de la mort alors de quelle façon j'en
sais rien mais enterré en tout cas les
intérêts qui nous a permis d'ailleurs de
les retrouver qui facilite ca
on va voir la grotte sas une
reconstitution mais voilà ça c'est de l'
architecture néandertaliens alors ça
c'est assez spectaculaire effectivement
ça c'est tout au fond d'un réseau
karstique donc imaginer plus de 100
mètres d'une entrée dans des grottes et
on a tous ces morceaux de stalagmites et
stalactites coup était positionné comme
ça pour délimiter un espace et dans
certaines zones on a retrouvé des foyers
c'est un peu reconstituée mais à peine
on a juste allumer le feu mais voilà
donc ça veut dire que et à cette période
armes connaît ça c'est en europe en
france même on ne connaît que des
néandertaliens cette période donc on en
déduit que les néandertaliens
c'était avait apprivoisé le milieu des
cavernes et s'était fait ce genre de
structures d'habitation quelque 100 va
voir lève mitochondrial oui enfin
mitochondrial sont nés tous
mitochondriaux pas reparler ses
finitions oui alors ça c'est oui bah
c'est juste une représentation d'une
femme
alors c'est vrai qu'à ça renvoie plutôt
à des données qui sont pas tout à fait
du domaine de la paie l'anthropologie
mais de la génétique de la
paléogénétique puisque grâce à ces
nouveaux outils
on arrive en travaillant sur les mythos
les mitochondries qui on veut à qui ce
transfert uniquement par les voilà qui
se transmet uniquement par les femmes
qu'on leur propre qu'on veut dire et
transmission de l'adn dont ils vont nous
donner d'informations sur les lignées
maternelles et puis le l'adn nucléaire
ce qui dans le vaio qui va qui est
l'objet de deux mélangés de aussi
d'évolution qui va être le marqueur de
la lignée paternelle
l'enfant de la gare vélo on ne voit pas
très bien parce qu'on a beaucoup pas
grandi à l'est se serait on s'est dit
que ça pouvait être un enfant résultant
de l'union d'un d'une femme
néandertalienne et d'un nouveau sa pièce
et d'un haut et d'un dos d'un homme
moderne femme moderne appelons le comme
ça oui ça a été une hypothèse
effectivement c'est toujours difficile
sur les enfants il yad'autres crâne dawa
0 en roumanie où là on voit où la
génétique a vraiment montré qu'il ya une
véritable mélange nand hertha lien
moderne mais ce qui est intéressant
finalement c'est que cette réponse de la
génétique nous montre que le cesu
humanité arrivait encore à se mélanger
et puis alors la question si on était
uniquement sur le régime de feu si on
dirait mais comment puisque la
définition d'une sous-espèce c'est que
deux populations peuvent se reproduire
entre elles mais il faut que leurs
descendants soit fertile
ça c'est la définition d'une sous-espèce
si on est que d un mélange d'espèces la
descendance ne sera pas fertile
alors si on était dans un cadre d'une
sépulture avec un an der tallien est une
femme moderne où l' inverse et qu'on est
con à un enfant c'est difficile de
savoir si cet enfant dans la maison est
décédé il pouvait se reproduire ou pas
toujours est il qu'on sait qu'on a dans
notre adn tous alors voilà quelques
pourcentages de devenir verte alliant
tout à fait alors nous européens
davantage de noms des italiens et nos
amis mélanésiens plutôt ce qu'on appelle
l'homme de denisova ce qu'un équivalent
géographique on va dire et en revanche
vous qui êtes sénégalais rien de
néandertaliens chez eux alors jusqu'à
présent on arrive à regarder de nouveau
vers tallinn chez eux
mais là on n'est pas à l'abri d'une
découverte et puis voilà voilà posé la
question à cheikh anta diop peut-être le
prochain prochaine image alors lui
serrer des flores c'est comme ça qu'on
l'appelle il faisait un médecin quand
même pas être amer mais d'ici là m mais
dix ans 1 m 10
il a disparu alors là où il alors la
relation n'a de nouvelles données sur
les datations longtemps cru qu'il avait
vécu jusqu'à dix huit ou douze mille ans
en fait il y avait des petits soucis de
concordance entre les strates qui ont
été datés les endroits où il a été
retrouvé
maintenant on dit plus tôt qu'il avait
vécu jusqu'à à peu près 60 mille ans est
par contre on en a trouvé des beaucoup
plus anciens à peu près 800 mille ans
toujours aux saisines indonésienne donc
voilà ça c'est une entité une humanité
différentes qui petit
donc un petit crâne et surtout ce qui
intéressant là c'est se dire finalement
l'homme il était peut-être encore
suffisamment malléable pour s'adapter à
différents environnements à différentes
époques et des époques passées on va
voir d'ailleurs plusieurs crânes
différent là sur cette image c'est alors
oui par ici on a en haut à gauche joue
là fait simplement on a un homo erectus
le un des plus complet et le plus
complet qu'on a en indonésie en bas à
droite qu'on a
l'homme moderne nous et c'est nous en
bas à gauche donc un néandertalien
européen est en haut à droite alors ça
c'est un crâne unique qu'est ce qu'on
appelle l'homme de rhodésie qui était
trouvé leur compte et ça ne peut pas le
dater mais d'un point de vue anatomique
il a des choses qui sont pas qui
ressemble comme ça grossièrement une
odeur sa gamme de cours rien à voir et
qui sont pour partie plus proche malgré
que ça soit pas évident de l'homme
moderne
alors il reste relativement peu de temps
avant la pause on va avancer
là on va voir l'homo sapiens idal tubes
ont ils nous ressemblent il est presque
comme nous ce qui est intéressant c'est
juste après on a le plus anciens objets
symboliques du monde
il est sept mille cinq cents ans 75 75
mille ans j'ai mal d'ici mais on a
trouvé des choses plus vieille encore 75
me lancer à bloc doc grave et voilà
alors ça c'est en en afrique du sud
c'est ce que je vous disais 1,75 milan
sarr plus de 30 mille ans la modernité
qu'on suppose être évidemment le fait
des européens c'est que la frise pas la
plante au logis c'est plutôt une source
occidentale au départ donc voilà
maintenant la réalité c'est que au jour
d'aujourd'hui on a on a des dates qui
vont épier ses empreintes de mains que
moi je trouve cette fascinante parce
qu'il y en a absolument partout et sur
tout les enlève sur l'art pariétal
l'année par huawei saint voy des mains
comme celle ci on est absolument partout
et moi je sois apprécié ils nous font
signe placez-vous 10 sél et nous quoi ça
pleut touche pas à mon pote de palau
lithiques 1 mais y'en a vraiment sur
tous les continents sont surtout les
continents alors on a du mal à les dates
et par contre ça c'est un peu plus
compliqué on sait pas non plus si c'est
des hommes 6 et des femmes 6 et des
enfants alors il ya eu quelques études
ou en fonction d'eux
les données anthropologiques on disait
qu'il y avait des des hommes et des
femmes et puis pour ce qui était des
enfants un moment s'est aperçu que
c'était plutôt des pattes de deux
reptiles qu'on avait dû couper puis on
avait soufflé dessus avec 2 log donc ce
n'était pas forcément des enfants
m'enfin ça ce sont des indices c'est
difficile de déterminer le sexe d'un
individu sur main quand on connaît pas
la variabilité de nos populations donc
ça je dirais c'est plus du folklore
voilà ça s'appelle homo sapiens et le
grand atlas qui vient de paraître chez
glénat ont fait une pause on se retrouve
juste après
[Musique]
c'est d'accord c'est un accord politique
ça va bien au delà d'une simple guerre
commerciale
il est clair que la chine avec un
beaucoup plus à perdre que les états
unis je suis pas convaincu tout de même
que le jeu ne soit pas plus équilibré
qu'il n'y paraît vous avez un certain
nombre de secteurs d'activité aux états
unis qui ont été lourdement impactés
s'aperçoivent qu'ils sont en train de
perdre leur statut de superpuissance et
unique superpuissance en la chine est un
pays qui peut beaucoup plus rapidement
que n'importe quel autre pays du monde
se passer des états unis et entraîné
avec elle en plus incertain d'autres
pays européens clés c'est aujourd'hui la
chine qui remet en cause l'hégémonie
américaine
[Musique]
j
et l'actualité c'est évidemment le
corona virus là aussi c'est un peu un
effet de la mondialisation
mon ami quand même plus d'un mois avant
que l'information remonte de ou ham
jusqu'à pékin dire que les premiers cas
du coronavirus remonte au mois de
novembre dans les effets économiques
commencent à se faire sentir et ils vont
se faire sortir notamment en france tous
des touristes non mais il ya eu quand
même des mesures très autoritaire de
prise bien sûr mais pour pouvoir stopper
là dedans un chien il n'y a que des
mesures autoritaires qui peuvent être
prises sk pas un message là en direction
de trumpf c'est constant chez les
chinois depuis toujours un
c'est nous avons réussi en 30 ans à nous
développer à un niveau vous ai mis deux
cents ans à le faire alors venez pas
nous donner des leçons alors là escapade
là aussi une autre leçon c'est que la
mondialisation dont on a dit pic et
pendre
on n'est pas très bien outillé c'est
qu'aujourd'hui quand une épidémie vient
de chine
bah elle se répand dans le monde entier
[Musique]
mes invités sont aujourd'hui valéry
zeitoun pour le grand atlas homo sapiens
benoît duteurtre pour son livre les
dents de la mer ou les souffrances d'un
piéton de paris et fadda freddy ngondo
dongo dit qu'ils sortent le sixième
album de daradji family il ya ma télé
daradji family c'est un groupe de hip
hop sénégalais il existe depuis 1997
paraît que vous avez fait près de 1000
concerts un peu partout dans le monde et
aujourd'hui vous sortez votre sim
sixième album
on va regarder tout de suite le clip de
chaque coup et les sk des clés de
compréhension qu'il faut posséder pour
pouvoir
ça fourmille d'allusions j'ai
l'impression et nous on les comprend pas
de doute c'est vrai que ce sont des
codes
il ya pas mal de code comme on fait peu
partout dans le monde il ya les codes
d'enracinement qu'on peut voir déco
dossier futuriste qu'on peut voir dans
cette vidéo
et il y à il ya aussi la charte du mandé
qui est qui est aussi codifié
là où se trouvent nos grands boubous
blancs mandingue et ses serments et
c'était la première jeudi reddition
constitution des droits de l'homme qui a
été fait au dos au mali dans la mire du
mali et ça depuis depuis le 14 avril
2014 et où le xvème siècle et ce sont
des codes comme ça qu'on a essayé un peu
de enfin on a fait un patchwork de ce
que c'est que une sorte d' afrocentrisme
et d'ouverture futuristic vers le monde
regarde ta grotte et bagnols
[Musique]
sa copine salades tartines à margate
alors on voit qu'il est question de
retour aux sources de transmission oui
aussi c'est un wolof
c'était un rôle à jouer mais ce qu'il
faut savoir c'est que chelsea écoulée
qu'on connaît en train de chanter si on
peut chanter dans beaucoup de pays et à
la bhl est à la base ça vient du ghana
et c'est un appel à l'unisson donc pour
manifester autour d'un même foyer
alors quand on écoute tout votre album
on a la pression vous attend on me dira
contre l'addiction aux écrans d'où le
titre d'ailleurs il ya ma télé il ya un
math et les c'est un personnage d'un
dessin animé
c'est une bande dessinée voici 6 rebonds
ce petit robot et qu'une télé sont en
vente sa date de la coupe du monde de
football de 82 ou alors on voit là à
gauche c'était le c'était la mascotte en
espagne louis de cette coupe du monde
et puis c'est le personnage alors ceux
liés à ma télé vous l'avez ressenti mais
comme il est très populaire au sénégal
les très populaires au sénégal je me
rappelle qu'à l'époque c'était avec la
avec avec l'espagne c'était espagne 1,82
à l'époque la ville et basile boli
tousart dominique rocheteau pour
l'équipe de france
et nous on était totalement câble et à
suivre les dessins animés et ce
personnage qui s'appelle 11 pour une
couronne coupé et ces personnages là et
elle pouvait tout faire il pouvait être
sur un des camps et puisse prolonger les
bras et puis touché la balle de l'autre
côté on était tellement fasciné et metz
qui était remarquable c'était la télé
qu'il transportait toujours sur le
ventre les cowboys et si haut si
aujourd'hui on a appelé l'album il ya ma
télé c'est un peu une auto critique par
rapport à ce que nous devenons
aujourd'hui lui transporté un écran sur
le ventre nous dans notre société
aujourd'hui chacun transporte un écran
dans les métros on se parle à peine
chacun a à peine baissé sur son écran on
voit même des foyers où il ya des
couples qui sont la côte à côte et
chacun est impressionné c'est comme ça
aussi au sénégal c'est partout dans le
monde au sénégal c'est
je veux dire entre le les telenovelas
les émissions de télé l'explosion de la
téléphonie parce que je pense qu'il y
aura à peu près 600 millions de
téléphones oui tu peux dire qu'en
afrique on va payer avec son téléphone
aussi par exemple vous êtes allé plus
vite que nous avons bien passé c'est
allé très vite
voilà très vite et même les papilles les
moments qui sont dans les villages tout
le monde est sur what's up to me la à
munich et tout le monde paye aussi
achète et envoient de l'argent puisque
nous en fait c'est un des plus gros
marchés en tout cas et donc et vous
pensez vraiment que les écrans rendent
fous les africains de la même manière
que les occidentaux ben je pense que
c'est un cetain s'éteint c'est une
propagation
je dirais même général est aujourd'hui
avant même si on avalise l'afrique on
avait déjà remarqué qu'il y avait une
certaine addiction
mais ce qui s'est passé en afrique c'est
à dire qu'il ya une une évasion mais
très très brutal parce que en plus de
2,2 d'avoir internet
il ya aussi toutes les toute l'industrie
téléphonique qui est venu en masse
s'installer parce que ils ont vu que la
démographie se développer assez vite et
que justement que l'afrique avait besoin
de réduire un peu le gap par rapport au
reste du monde même si des gens comme le
professeur phil woods sarko n'a cité que
ça leur dit ce que l'afrique n'a
personne à rattraper la population a
soif de de toucher le monde de savoir ce
qui se passe dans le monde et même de
s'actualiser par rapport à ce qui se
passe aux etats unis est le rêve qu'on
aura déjà vendu qu on est à fond sur les
écrans découvre qu'on peut communiquer
avec l'autre tout ça peut être
formidable
par exemple les livres numériques ce
dont souffre l'afrique c'est qu'il ya
pas de bibliothèque très très peu là
peut-être que ce garçon qu'on voit là il
peut dit-il en train de dire shakespeare
justement le fond du message c'est ça
c'est que les jeunes les plus jeunes en
fait bad et qu'ils ont accès à aux
écrans bas ils vont ils vont tomber dans
l'est dans les pays des rives de
tu vois de com de vraiment aller
découvrir le dernier film qui est sorti
le dernier sont dédiées etc
je pense que le fond du message c'est
que ces jeunes là doit profiter de la
technologie a pour acquérir de la
connaissance parce que aujourd'hui on a
un google on l'a eue que wikipédia et
cetera mais je pense que les en tout cas
les petites comme on les appelle les
nouvelles technologies doivent permettre
aux jeunes africains de créer de start
up et aussi de se développer de
connaître un peu mieux le monde quoi
cette chanson dans cet album dans lequel
vous expliquer que le pouvoir et
l'argent
ça rend fou plus particulièrement en
afrique où partout là aussi bas au
départ on a l'impression de croire que
c'est en afrique quand on voit qu'il ya
une certaine dictature de temps en temps
et même des présidents qui veulent être
élu président à vie qui parfois sont
plus ou moins soutenue ou de manière
indirecte par par l'europe mais ce qui
se passe est qui et qui rigolo c'est que
on souffre du même syndrome partout dans
le monde
on voit qu'au départ les politiques sont
sympathiques et une fois qu'il
s'installe au pouvoir ils ont envie de
passer automatiquement
donc c'est une c'est une addiction au
pouvoir qu'on a simplement remarqué ça
arrive partout même chez les musiciens
etc partout dans le monde
quand plus on a de l'argent et plus on
en veut plus on a du pouvoir et plus on
n'en veut dans quelque part oui c'est
une c est ce que les jeunes africains
aujourd'hui est-ce qu'ils sont
conscients de ceux d'autres ont parlé
avec valéry zeitoun à savoir que toute
l'humanité via d'afrique
ils sont conscients de cela parce qu'on
a quand même eu la chance d'avoir un
très grand homme chez nous chers anta
diop kim qui a écrit nationale guy
culture et qui nous a même si c'est je
veux dire 1% ou 0 % il a permis à
beaucoup de jeunes africains d'avoir
cette reconnaissance là même avec les
l'égyptologie etc
mais c'est vrai qu'il ya un travail à
faire parce que tout simplement comme
ils le disent et aujourd'hui les jeunes
ils rêvent d'aller en europe ils rêvent
d'aller en offrant aux états unis et il
faudra falloir qu'on n'inverse la
tendance et qui au final une
considération surtout par rapport à
recours à ce déséquilibre qui entre le
fait de se
de se desserrer disons tigre est
identifié par rapport à la colonisation
et puis de s'enraciner pour justement
accepter même pour certains africains
qu'effectivement les problèmes maison
venait d'afrique
autre extrait du morceau qui s'intitule
diamono ça veut dire quoi de janot
ça veut dire le temps l'époque et c'est
un morceau qu'on a écrit à dakar parce
qu'on a comme je disais tout à l'heure
on voit un peu jusqu'à présent le nombre
de jeunes qui veulent voyager mais voilà
quoi par tous les moyens pour une
nouvelle sortie d'afrique
voilà donc ce morceau là parler un peu
de ce voyage là mais en fin de contrat
mais aussi une touche positive parce que
c'est pas juste voilà dresser un tableau
tout le monde le sait mais donner de
l'espoir à ces jeunes là pour qui croire
pour qu'il soit beaucoup plus confiants
parce que au final on peut avoir des
diplômes
on peut avoir certains statuts mais des
fois les gens sont découragés parce
qu'il faut avoir des bras longs il faut
tu vois il faut vraiment rimé pour
accéder à un certain niveau mais on dit
à ces jeunes là que il est possible en
tout cas de réussir en afrique on vous
regarde
[Musique]
le maillot du ghana
mais bon
ça
vous serez amené à 12 heures
joe lando fed évoqueront notamment à la
mauvaise humeur
ta maman
c'est une
[Musique]
beaucoup de monde
du coton
[Musique]
du coup de mou
j'écoute
du côté d'un mormon
john cornu johnny ramone fly d'inhumer
l'est de la ville soit quelques mois
kenta biotech connexion by dakar et de
moyenne et relégué bienveillant le média
mieux nous oublions mont d'or fenioux 9
milliards can mondial et je tenais mon
bic ya quelqu'un de différent nous
guette si la monétique n'y a que par ici
de leucan mauricie à grammont tout est
assez limité loria qui clique et souriez
défi les actualités de minuit dit qe
vous le bungalow de parler du couteau du
coup dûr
tu que dans
mon mieux demain
non
j'écoute dans mon nom
du coup de menton
voilà daradji family vous serez au
trianon en concert vendredi prochain
nombreux sur scène ou que tous les deux
on a une formation live parce qu'on fait
on fait du hip hop mais c'est quand même
lui qui est jouée sur scène donc on a
basse batterie guitare clavier et une
choriste qui nous accompagne sur scène
quoi voilà et bien bonne chance
[Musique]
benoît duteurtre vous êtes écrivain et
depuis tout doit disparaître en 1992
c'est votre deuxième roman avec des
livres comme l'un d'eux tjd buffet de
gare qui est paru lui beaucoup plus
récemment vous dénoncer avec humour et
mélancolie les ravages de la modernité
c'est encore le cas dans les dents de la
mer qui vient de paraître chez fayard
vous vous racontez vos souffrances de
parisiens et même de piétons parisien on
a l'impression que votre vie est devenue
un enfer
benoît duteurtre on peut plus être
piéton dans une grande ville comme paris
après on se dit c'est à belvis piétons
et les seuls qui ne connaissent pas les
embouteillages c'est le point de départ
du livre c'est qu'il ya effectivement ce
discours de paris et beaucoup d'autres
villes c'est qu'on lutte contre l'
automobile et donc au service de tous
les autres et moi qui suis vraiment
l'incarnation pourrait dire dans un
certain côté du bo bo je vis au centre
de paris dans des milieux artistiques ou
culturelles je ne sais pas conduire je
n'ai pas de voiture mais je suis piétons
et je suis objectivement une victime de
cette politique anti voiture puisque la
politique anti voitures non seulement à
mon avis n'a pas très bien fonctionné
mais à créer de nouvelles nuisances un
peu partout dans une ville comme paris
parce que en retirant les voitures d'un
endroit et vont à un autre il ya des
quartiers où qui eût qu'ils ne
connaissaient pas les embouteillages qui
sont maintenant complètement envahis par
ces malheureux automobiliste qui essaie
de rentrer chez eux le soir mais surtout
il ya ces fameuses circulations douces
elles sont pires ennemis les circulades
rhinau et là trottinent elle est alors
ça s'appelle circulations douces mais
quand vous sortez vous de chez vous
comme ça et puis il ya une trottinette
qui vous passe juste devant qui manquent
de vous renversez c'est pas très doux et
vous avancez un petit peu plus loin vous
passez sur un passage clouté un passage
protégé il ya un cycliste qui passent à
toute vitesse qui vous grille la
politesse vous dit écoutez faites
attention il serait mieux
il vous fait un doigt d'honneur il va te
faire [ __ ] c'est ce qu'on appelle les
circulations dont sur 10 km
vous avez toujours vous ne conduisez pas
vous avez sur une impression que
l'automobiliste c'est un être humain
normal mais qui dès qu'il se met au
volant de peut devenir un barbare ah oui
tiens je croyais que c'était réservé aux
automobiles
et en maintenant parce qu'on sait très
bien que l'automobiliste effectivement
une mauvaise foi extraordinaire il ne
reconnaît jamais sa faute il commence
toujours par engueuler nôtre mais en
fait le cycliste a repris exactement
tous les torts de l'automobiliste à dire
qu'il n'est jamais en faute
d'autant plus qu'on lui a expliqué qu'il
était le développement durable à rouler
vidal et amsterdam ou febiac amsterdam
les les piétons ne craignent pas les
voitures et craignent les vélos tous les
accidents c'est et des vélos qui les
causes contre des piétons oui et c'est
pareil
la peur du vélo est à peu près la même
que celle qui existait autrefois la peur
de la voiture chez les piétons et jeu
finit même par me demander j'avais fait
un peu la comparaison entre avec cyril
et que les gaullistes et les communistes
au début la vème république qu'ils
arrivaient à cohabiter et va les cycles
et piétons et les voitures il arrivait à
cohabiter il avait un modus vivendi
les uns avaient le trottoir les autres
avaient la chaussée ça fonctionnait à
peu près mais aujourd'hui tout ça était
complètement déréglé vélo et les
trottinettes route sur les trottoirs ils
roulent sur les trottoirs ils roulent
sur les passages protégés ils grillent
les feux rouges
il roule à contresens pourquoi parce
qu'on leur a expliqué qu'ils étaient la
vertu incarner ils allaient sauver la
planète et que donc on ne peut
absolument rien leur reprocher ils ont
cette arrogance de ceux qui protègent
les autres mais en les faisant souffrir
c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui le nouveau
coupable pendant très longtemps on a
encouragé les automobilistes
en france on entend encourager aussi les
mobylettes parce que les fabriquer est
le premier fabricant européen pour ça
qu'on l'encouragé pas le vélo parce
qu'on a corrigé la mobylette aujourd'hui
à plus le mobile est donc on encourage
le vélo enfin sud où il va encore
quelques mobylette mais c'est plus un
marché aussi important donc aujourd'hui
le nouveau coupable de tout bois tous
les crimes c'est l'automobile contre lui
on a tous les droits comme contre un
fumeur mais sauf que faut quand même pas
oublier d'où on vient moi j'avais même
écrit un petit un petit pamphlet que
c'était le grand embouteillage vous il
ya beaucoup trop de voitures je chante
je suis d'accord mais on a quand même
construit un monde depuis un siècle
autour de l'automobilisme de façon
excessive d'ailleurs on a poussé les
gens à avoir des avis et des voitures on
les a obligés à avoir des voitures parce
qu'on peut plus faire les courses près
de chez soi pour se déplacer tout le
temps et on a fait rêver les lignes
secondaires du train voilà on a sué
absolument à supprimer beaucoup de
trains et tout d'un coup dur
au lendemain après un ciel de
construction dans un certain sens on
vous dit allez on va tout changer en
cinq ans ou en dix ans les
automobilistes sont les coupables
il faut tout arrêter il faut tout
changer il ya une espèce de démesure
dans ce retournement
au regard de ce qu'est la vie
quotidienne simplement de millions de
gens notamment en banlieue parisienne
qui me paraît effectivement pas très pas
très bien alors dans dans ce livre vous
attaquez également à des choses qui
paraissent totalement innocente comme
ron my city and my city
c'est quelque chose qu'on peut voir de
nombreuses grandes villes c'est devenu
quasiment une marque voilà nous c'est en
mai à paris et ne rien dire un cours ma
ville oui voici ont dû courir une ville
vous dire courir les magasins dont
conscient pour les magasins en cours
avec un téléphone portable on prend des
photos on se connaît et c'est en gros on
court on redécouvre sa ville en courant
ça ça vous agace
alors chers à new york à londres par
tout d'abord le fait que ce soit en
anglais ça m'agace déjà dû courir
président d'iron man city on peut dire
ça en français secundo effectivement
c'est une marque c'est encore cette
chose dont je parlais tout à l'heure
c'est l'invasion de la ville par les
marques
et effectivement voilà c'est une marque
comme les vélos les vélib les
trottinettes tout ça sont ils ont tous
une couleur une marque un peu et la
ville n'ai pris qu'un étalement de
marque partout mais troisièmement il se
trouve que c'est un livre assez
personnelle assez concret moi j'habite
près de l'hôtel de ville et il démarre
sur la place de l'hôtel de ville avec
des tambours au petit matin dimanche et
la place de l'hôtel de ville c'est
devenu une espèce d'animation permanente
ça ne s'arrête jamais et ça c'est aussi
un nouvel aspect de la politique urbaine
c'est que tous les maires se veulent
organisateurs tout le temps de fêtes
alors il ya la technoparade ya la gay
pride ce coin mais aussi la fête de
l'air la fête de l'eau la fête des
familles est toujours une fête place de
l'hôtel de ville et je vous assure c'est
pas tellement agréable quand on aime
paris quand on aime déambuler quand on
aime une certaine quiétude urbaine et
est alors par exemple les fans zone
j'imagine que ça aussi les fameuses
aides au transport mais qu'est ce que
vous pouvez bien reprocher à des trucs
aussi sympa que ça parce que ça sent pas
le champ de mars comme ça et franchement
la russie et qui sont là ont l'air de
trouver ça sonne
en tout cas en tout cas pour revenir au
vélo vous parliez du sport mais
évidemment tout ça rejoint aussi une
chose qui est tout à fait notre époque
et l'injonction de l'entretien de soi
parce que le vélo c'est aussi ça au fond
finalement si on veut mettre en avant le
vélo c'est que chacun doit faire
attention à son corps s'entretenir
entretenir sa santé c'est pour ça que le
vélo évidemment à une telle cote
moi je veux être un peu d'une ancienne
dans cette manière alors là c'est du
sport mais c'est du sport qu'on ne fait
pas assez du sport qu'on regarde pour
rien il faut pas confondre quand on
regarde du sport on ne fait pas du sport
mais néanmoins la fan zone alors déjà
c'est vrai que le nom est un peu
agressif at the way et puis le champ de
mars et est dans un état de désolation
abominable c'est vraiment des beaux
endroits de paris aussi un très joli
quartier confié la tour eiffel on
pourrait simplement avoir envie de se
promener
il faut toujours c'est pas tous les
jours c'est souvent c'est comme un tout
le parvis de l'hôtel de ville c'est un
enchaînement perpétuelle d'animation
d'organisation dans ce pays d'ailleurs
beaucoup les habitants ont là on va dire
c'est le septième c'est les plus beaux
quartiers de paris enfin sont aussi des
habitants de paris qui au fond on voit
ce que la fille de m la béquille vers
des fraudes partout
non ce qui me fait plus peur des jeux
olympiques sont tous les périmètres de
sécurité aussi qu'ils sont là alors là
pour le coup c'est pas la ville
d'ailleurs c'est plutôt l'état
mais à la suite des phénomènes de gilet
jaune des attentats etc
maintenant dès qu'il se passe quelque
chose on vous fait un périmètre qui
veulent tout un quartier on ferme tout
personne ne peut pas c est moi qui
habite près de notre dame je raconte
dans un livre
combien de fois est ce que j'ai
simplement pas pu rentrer dans ma rue on
m'interdisait de rentrer chez les
dernières fois c'était d'ailleurs on va
voir c'était pendant l'incendié de notre
dame
on a essayé de vous sortir de chez vous
jusqu'à et évacué tous les habitants
autour parce qu'on risquait ça risquait
de s'écrouler vous être et sauf que mon
immeuble est assez loin en fait de notre
âme et il était sur l'île donc à
l'intérieur du périmètre
et quand j'ai vu là se fait horrible
incendie je suis rentré en courant chez
moi parce que ma première idée ça a été
ils vont nous évacuer ils vont nous
évacuer j'ai couru jusqu'à l'appartement
où on s'est enfermés l'oreille avec mon
amie dans la nuit
comme ça et vous savez que les autres
voisins de l'immeuble ont cédé se sont
laissés entraîner vers le gymnase des
blancs manteaux où on leur a offert quoi
deviner une cellule d'assistance
psychologique est aussi indispensable
le vol mais alors ça c'est bon avant
cela il y avait des tourismes des
touristes dans notre dame le tourisme
staff et d'un même d'aujourd'hui qui
gagne alors toutes les grandes villes
les les français ont l'impression qu'on
découvre le tourisme avant c'est les
touristes ils allaient sur la côte
aujourd'hui sont dans paris ils sont ils
sont pas non seulement d'en bas ils sont
partout dans paris ils sont passés à
l'opéra comme autrefois on disait les
japonais vont à l'opéra et puis c'est
tout non ils sont partout avec tout
alors là vous voyez encore c'est une
marque bien à trois ou quatre comme ça
de ces écarts qui traverse paris en
permanence je dois dire moi peut-être je
suis privilégié je ne sais quoi enfin
quand j'ai visité une ville j'ai
toujours eu le bonheur de la visite et
par les moyens du bord de prendre les
transports en commun de me balader et
c'est là c'est plutôt du transport de
masse qui est en permanence dans paris
et qui contribuent assez gravement je
dois verhoek aux problèmes de
circulation alors donc on s'en prend
beaucoup à l'automobiliste individuelles
qui travaille à paris etc
mais la ville a favorisé l'accroissement
comme ça de ceux de ce flux touristiques
ça a même été aujourd'hui on est encore
une électorale donc le discours est un
peu plus modérée mais ça a été un
objectif affiché
mais augmenter le tourisme de temps pour
des engagements de l'état l'état veut
plus de touristes les mairies veulent
plus de touristes les tories c'est la
sellor de l'avenir on dirait c'est ce
que pense mon ami ou el bec d'ailleurs
que c'est le tourisme qui va sauver la
france
m mais je peux vous assurer que quand on
vit dans ce qui était juste un quartier
et qui est devenu de fait un bazar à
touristes et qui dans le cas d'un grand
plan de transformation de l'île de la
cité va devenir non plus un bazar
truisme une balade touristique au cours
des prochaines années si c'est
fatalement versant il n'y a plus que des
souvenirs pour touristes et restaurants
sont ouvriers ou des faux restaurant
franchouillard avec des types en bleu
blanc rouge et ses dix talents elle le
clip sur le quartier
et puis il ya un projet de
transformation comme ça de toute la
dalle de notre dame en grande base
touristique il ya un projet de
transformation du merveilleux marché aux
fleurs de l'île de la cité qu'on se
recouvrir m
loches en verre pour faire des
animations à l'intérieur c'est ce qu'est
ce qu'il ya plus vert plus écologique
plus d'eau plus un rêve qu'un petit
marché aux fleurs anciens au coeur de la
ville pourquoi ne pas protéger cette
merveilleuse ville de paris avec son
harmonie et son équilibre tout qui
attire les gens du monde entier
le bruit vous dites que ça augmentait
mais je me dis attendez par rapport au
bruit qui devait y avoir une île comme
paris au xixème siècle du temps où il y
avait des chevaux calèche des pavés des
ateliers des débuts du sinn féin en bd
je dis même je suis tout à fait je pense
que claire sur la question mode harmonie
j'ai beaucoup haussmann il se trouve que
je pense que les travaux d'haussmann ça
doit être quelque chose d'extrêmement
pénible à vivre pour l'élégance de dire
que peut être vous lira dans 50 ans et
c'est beau quand vous comme on se moque
aujourd'hui de ceux qui souffraient des
travaux d'haussmann voilà qu'ils disent
est un sauvage est en fait il était en
train d'accoucher d'une ville d'un
défilé fut accepté une espèce de génie
en même temps voilà mais je crois qu'il
ya une vieille chose contre ce mal qui
est un peu dans la culture gauchistes
aussi quai comme c'est l'homme qui a
élargi les boulevards et qui a permis la
répression de la commune il faudra
oublier que c'était surtout pour éviter
les microbes les grandes il a eu ce
génie de créer une ville aérée ouverte
extraordinairement propice à la
circulation avant même la naissance de
l'automobile c'est en ça qu il était 19
h sont visionnaires parce que le
boulevard haussmannien c'est vrai que il
élargit permet une grande circulation
des flux à l'intérieur de la ville et
aujourd'hui personne a l'impression
qu'on fait exactement le contraire
c'était quand on referme ce grands
boulevards haussmanniens en créant une
série de couloirs salles communautarisme
des couloirs alors il ya les piétons et
les cyclistes
il ya les vélos les taxis les bus et
tout le monde serait ce défi un peu des
autres dans cette espèce de vous avoir
déformés et rétrécies c'est comme ça que
vous voyez des grandes villes comme
paris vous traversez aujourd'hui
en tournée ou ailleurs ou ici vous
voudrez corp nbc souvent c'est vrai que
ça fait quelques années plus d'une
vingtaine d'années qu'on fait des allers
retours entre entre l'afrique et paris
mais c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui ce qu'ils
disent est vrai parfois sur juste quand
on marche comme ça on voit des scop des
soucoupes volantes avec des offres
dessus qui font comme ça et c'est assez
drôle à voix est parfois on a
l'impression d'être un peu submergé
mais paris garde quand même c'est quand
même une ville qui fait tellement rêver
parce que qu'on va aux états unis on
parle de paille comme la ville de
l'amour il ya toujours un coeur qui bat
à paris et nous on est concentré sur ce
que là c'est ce que artistique
ce père qui voit ce métissage et qui
voit que l'humanité aussi présente donc
c'est ce que relate qui en tout cas qui
nous qui nous parle à paris les dents de
la mer de benoît duteurtre ça vient de
paraître chez fayard
le grand atlas au bo sapiens de valéry
zeitoun est tellement pied vanille c'est
chez glénat et le nouvel album de
daradji family qui s'intitule il ya ma
télé
vous serez en concert avec au trianon
vendredi prochain merci de nous avoir
suivis et rendez vous au prochain numéro
[Musique]